Its the same wedding.
its the same celebration no matter what table you are at
you this is where I'm sitting so if you
end up in the high teens you know where.
to find me today to mess up hi hello my
god hi I'm renzo like a cheap too buddy.
and I'm in a rock band I Walter and
level service provision I'm Cranston.
email list for spamming I can smell the
toilet from here that's how well we know
the brining room I'm Eloise I got dumped
by Francis brother the SS man back there
table 10 nope this is a great table it's
a great one no it isn't yes not it we
didn't think you'd be coming RSVP no and
then yes an RSVP cards that you barbecue
for two years you break up with the
other tech groupie what's with your
future endeavors are you firing me
issues
you know what Francis mother cross table
19 the people that should have known to
send regrets but not before sending
something nice off the registry was able
to disappear in the middle of the
wedding and no one would even notice the
table of people they don't care about
how are we come on back here let's go
what if you came here for a different
reason today what if you went away with
something better hey do you have that
kind of day await the things that comes
so easily to everyone else's same so
Lucy's No yeah lenina I come to you
asking for Megan Anne's hand in this
tent and the rest of her body along with
that hand this is not going to hack so
you could just stand awkwardly in front
of another table lovely statue you how
did I not just get kiss it happens more
often than you think
you are Romeo and Juliet and we all wish
you the same happy ending i will give
you twenty dollars and stand up right
now alright what honey oh how long have
you worked here